i'm kennedy anderson um i'm 17 and i'm
from cross a virginia american idol
contestant kennedy anderson makes a
shocking exit from the reality singing
competition there's been a few people
that have even tried out
in this season five that like it's going
to be amazing to see their journey we
really want to see these kids shine the
18 year old singer announced her
decision to leave on monday writing on
instagram quote for personal reasons i'm
unable to continue on american idol this
has been one of the hardest decisions
i've ever had to make but i know it's
necessary
while the musician didn't go into detail
she did say she's grateful to ai the
judges the producers the contestants and
all the fans who supported her
waiting
on
for
a rep from fremantle the production
company behind idol released a statement
to et explaining quote we are
disappointed to see kennedy leave but we
are excited to watch this celebratory
20th season unfold with the incredible
talent vying to be the next american
idol
20 years ago i was touring around the
world and someone said to me
this american idol
what is it all about i don't know
and here i am 20 years later five years
five seasons in
it's the story to be told it's a
highlight are we really seeing people
come out of the woodwork for season 20.
well i mean we're really topping
ourselves we can see those diamonds in
the rough
way that you'll cheer and scream for me
[Music]
kennedy's announcement comes just weeks
after idol judges katy perry lionel
richie and luke bryan were blown away by
her vocal chops i'm feeling threatened
they're younger
they are
they're prettier they seem really good
siri make an appointment at the plastic
surgeon
i don't know how you haven't
been
recruited
you have graced us because your voice
your look your sound if that's 17 years
old
congratulations you might be the biggest
star we've ever seen i don't want to
send them to hollywood
if unless i really think they're going
to get in there and compete so i've been
a little tougher this year not only did
that audition earn her the second of
three platinum tickets sending her
straight to hollywood you
are
going to
her cover of lady gaga's applause was a
top trending topic on youtube in early
march
[Music]
having a kid standing in front of you
and you know they're nervous and you
know what that feels like and you know
they want to be a star and you know what
that feels like and so i'm really
imparting wisdom
that i love because
when i see them i'm not looking at them
as a contestant i'm looking at it as
myself
kennedy documented some of the
highlights from her idol journey on
instagram including the moment she
performed an original tune for the
judges
[Applause]
[Music]
kennedy wrote in her caption that the
experience was so cool before thanking
fans for all the love
[Music]
you